meine alte schule das gymnasium
kreuzgasse sieht noch genauso aus wie
vor 23 jahren
denn schon vor 23 jahren war alles im
arsch deshalb gehen jetzt in den
bundestag und sorge mit einer
spektakulären nie dagewesene aktion
dafür dass berlin endlich die kohle
locker macht ich war in meiner alten
schule die sieht schlimm aus
ich möchte da gerne hingehen und denen
was bieten zu sagen
sie können jetzt ein zeichen setzen und
was spenden so die da 50 erscheine die
können sie ruhig auspacken um 10 das
natürlich immer super jaja sondern nur
ordentlich rein tun damit er auch drin
bleibt nah und für die schule
das heißt es wird wichtig denn hier
hallo sie sind bestimmt von der fdp
sondern und der cdu aber wenn so was von
dir wollen möglichst bei mir anmelden
könnten fußball hin anmelden
jena ist schon ein ordentlicher soll ich
machen auch künast hat auch noch ein
bisschen mehr gespendet
die hatten kunst sogar ein stück ist ein
15 reingesteckt dann gehen da sind auch
50 habe zwei kinder einer ausbildung
zählen müssen frau künast
der herr lambsdorff hat mehr gegeben der
ist hoferer eingesteckt
konzipiert ist ja auch ist die sache
aufgeflogen
hier sagt er sie haben 50 euro sparen
gedanken trage kein bargeld bei mir so
kann man sich natürlich natürlich auch
ausreden wenn sie sonst aber es würden
sie nach hausmeistertätigkeit übernehmen
vielleicht an der schule so ein
praktikum an der schule finde ich keine
schlechte idee
und das wäre okay wenn ich das noch
filme und sie machen das ja ich würde
mal sagen ich würde ihnen auch schon mal
zeigen wie man hummer irgendwie wand
haut vielleicht besser anlage mit dem
hammer in die wahl
sie haben aber auch nicht so richtig an
uns das geht uns nie mehr bildung
warum haben bildung ist sehr schön sehr
selbstkritisch fand ich ihn baumschule
gewesen
ich bin den baum sorgt erkennen habe
sonst nix gute frisur enix verstehen ja
so nachhilfe in humor wer da noch mal
ganz 32 euro ist relativ wenig herr
oppermann hat ein profi reingesteckt
also zwei euro ist alles was ich bin das
ist alles was ich beim jahre für zehn
euro können sie eine firma ihres
vertrauens nennen
siemens ich habe gesagt ich helfe ich
gehe nach berlin und ich kriege geld
jetzt von ihnen und von ihm
wo sind sie denn zur schule gegangen und
gymnasium kreuzgasse wo ist da ist in
köln das habe ich nicht erfunden
das waren ja fünf cent nur das glaube
ich nicht okay war gelogen
aber ein bisschen mehr als fünf cent das
ist ja du willst eine beleidigung für
meine schule so ich bin zurück
schulpflegschaft und förderverein sind
schon daher flach herford ich habe gute
nachrichten die schule ist gerettet
wir schauen jetzt mal wie viel geld
zusammengekommen ist ja sind 35 euro 58
reicht das die schule zu sanieren
das bringt uns weiter ein paar
zentimeter
ja wir freuen uns ja wir sind auf gutem
weg ist weil sich die schule für einen
tag schön zu sagen habe damals auch so
gemacht wie glücklich - und damit zurück
ins studium
[Applaus]